foreign
I want you to Envision a single piece of
artwork generated by artificial
intelligence
when most of us think of AI art
I bet we're imagining something like
this
we're all probably picturing something
totally different
today with machine learning models like
Dolly stable diffusion and mid-journey
we've seen AI produce everything from
strange life forms
to imaginary influencers
to entirely foreign curious kinds of
imagery
AI as a technology is fascinating to us
because we're inherently drawn to things
we cannot understand
and with neural networks processing data
from thousands of other images made by
people from every possible generation
every art movement
millions of images in one simple scan
they can produce visuals that are so
familiar yet strikingly unfamiliar more
poetically AI mirrors us
the world is beginning to change right
before our very eyes and it's basically
divided into two schools of thought
there are pessimists who think AI poses
a great threat to human creativity
and then optimists who see it as an
extension of our creativity
so is it even possible to be truly
original as an artist anymore
how do we begin to critically engage
with artworks made by machines
we can start by looking at some
metaphors narratives and insights from
artists who are truly pushing the
boundaries of AI
let's look to these moments of delight
surprise confusion and wonder
they give us just one small glimpse into
the possibilities of encounter with this
technology because as we've seen this is
a very moral and ethical encounter
as much as an aesthetic one
Mario klingerman sold this piece on
auction in 2019 it is running an AI
model trained on thousands of portraits
from the 17th to 19th centuries
the model constantly reveals uncanny
interpretations of the human face each
one is unique generated in real time as
the machine reads its own output
for the viewer it's almost like peering
into the machine's hallucinations as it
conjures each new portrait
Sophia Crespo series neural Zoo uses
neural network interpretations of the
real world to generate unreal sea
creatures and diverse biological forms
frogs look like flowers
translucent jellyfish have vivid
internal organs there's no one real
creature in these images but AI allows
us to Envision otherworldly life forms
in impossible detail
this abstract piece by Sarah Ludy began
as a digital painting it was augmented
to fit a 16x9 ratio using a prompt for
torn edges in Dali 2's out painting
outpainting allows artists to extend
their creativity beyond the frame using
simple language prompts like torn edges
this piece by Ivana Tau might read as a
photograph but it is also the work of AI
it's the result of Gan training on
thousands of images from the artist's
personal photo collection
Tau curates from her own photographs
carefully choosing the inputs and
outputs for the model
in many ways AI art is a form of
curation it becomes the process of
selecting from hundreds of images at a
time
this video pulls from Models trained on
a massive data set of Taos photos
resulting in a kind of algorithmic
memory
but she also created a destructive data
set for the model to symbolize
forgetting or fleeting memory
and finally we have Claire silver
has called herself a collaborative AI
artist in that she works intentionally
with the machine to produce her art
her process is constantly evolving as
the tools evolve
she often Works within painting
techniques masking and transforming just
one small piece of an image
for this portrait she shifted the
opacity of various sections with an
apple pencil transforming it bit by bit
she Likens this technique to her version
of glazing and oil painting
silver feeds AI generated images from
one model into another effectively
creating new forms of language and
understanding for the machine itself
her work is half master painting half
digital art both old and new
this piece pulls inspiration from famed
artists like John Singer Sergeant Evelyn
de Morgan and Gustav Klimt almost as an
homage
because different AI models are trained
on different sets of information it's
almost like they're all speaking
different languages
AI is everywhere now we are all now
collectively co-creating with AI whether
we're aware of it or not
if we want to be a part of these worlds
we cannot design alone if we want to be
culturally literate in these new kinds
of images and predictions and forms
then looking to the work of artists is a
very productive place to start
we need to brace ourselves for an
increasingly technological future which
is only going to multiply all the
creative possibilities at our fingertips
now
thank you
[Applause]